when you train with these guys who
trained Keanu Reeves for John wick it
seems like you're breaking your thumbs
you're breaking your ribs the training
is intense and I'm and I'm like I
thought there's stunt people for that
stuff why are you damaging yourself I I
have to say I mean I meant it even this
some injury wasn't that bad like even if
a stunt person did this it wouldn't have
helped I grabbed on to a guy and my
thumb got stuck in his like wardrobe and
he turned and he just kind of bent my
son back quiz him so I tore the ligament
off the bone and then I remembered the
first action movie ever did was a film
called young slugs I hurt myself
actually pretty bad on that because
there was a level of like we want you to
be crazy supple because this anime
character that's not even real is like
you know constantly in the splits or
like you know in back bends and I was
like it's not I can't do that so they
put me with these searches to lay people
who were lovely but they were
double-jointed and weird and I was like
I have three months like I'm not gonna
be able to like you know smell my own
[ __ ] in a backbend it's not gonna
happen
so let's find something that I can do
but in a in flux you almost got
paralyzed you fell on your head or
something trying to do one of these
quacks doing back handsprings I'm not a
gymnast right you're not in three months
so this I think now for me it's all
about having the right team you don't
need a stunt person to step in and do
something you created to be something
that you can do and that's what makes it
fun when you have choreography that is
there to celebrate you as an actor to
tell the story not like make have a
stunt person step into making look good
it's like we're telling a story the
actor is doing it they've worked for
four months it's like rehearsal they
know exactly what they're doing
that's [ __ ] awesome when you can do
that I'm safe will you count up the box
off you're now one of the number one
action stars for years you know was
somewhat frustrating for me as a woman
because I
like the genre I like watching these
movies like I grew up my mom loved Chuck
Norris and Charles Bronson and like it
makes me feel you know it makes me feel
good about just knowing that we've
changed that industry as a whole like I
feel like there's onra has definitely
had a facelift and I feel like women
have been a huge part in that like I
feel like women have kind of like
stepped up in the genre and made it fun
again and and not made it just part of
this one conversation where just like oh
well women can't fight like man well we
don't want to [ __ ] fight like men we
want to fight like we would fight